[Music]
fear not the title of this video is just
a test actually capitalism is cool in
fact it's the coolest the reason we
titled this video as such was because my
direct message this week titled
socialism isn't cool was d monetized by
YouTube so we wanted to run a little
test here and see if this video gets
demonetised as well of course capitalism
ensures that YouTube has the right to do
whatever it wants and nobody is forcing
me to be a creator here but at the same
time I can use my voice to try to make
the platform better for creators and
just a bit more transparent that is the
beauty of a free society you can speak
up when you see a problem and it's no
coincidence that most free societies are
also capitalist ones so to be absolutely
crystal clear socialism isn't cool and
capitalism is cool will this video be be
monetized for mocking capitalism in the
title the way our socialism video was
well I'll let you know in the comments
right down below
[Music]
you